To design a locality aware algorithm,
you need a machine model.
We'll use a variation on
the von Neumann architecture.
Here's a picture of
von Neumann from 1956.
The von Neumann architecture
has a processor.
For the moment,
assume the processor is sequential.
This processor does basic
computing operations.
These are things like addition,
subtraction, branches, and so on.
Now the processor connects to a main
memory, you regard this memory as being
nearly infinite but really slow,
hang on, I'm a coming, I'm a coming.
Between the processor and
the slow memory there's a fast memory,
however the memory is also small.
Let's denote the size of this memory
by capital Z measured in words.
You're probably already familiar
with two-level memory hierarchies.
Consider, for example,
a real processor like an Intel
Ivy Bridge multi-core processor.
The fast memory might be, say,
a last-level cache that sits between
a slower main memory, not shown
in the photo and the processor.
Or what about this example?
This is an Adapteva Parallella board
which is collecting dust in my office.
It's collecting dust mostly because I'm
sitting around drawing cartoons instead
of doing, say, real hacking.
Do I even know how to program anymore?
The Parallella has a slow, non-volatile
SD card which acts as a disc.
It also has a smaller
amount of main memory.
Pulling data out of main memory is a lot
faster than pulling it off the SD card.
Okay, where was I?
Oh, right.
There are two rules about how
computations run in this model.
Here's the first rule.
The processor cannot do any operations
unless the operands sit in fast memory.
I'll refer to this as
the local data rule.
Here's the second rule.
It's called the block transfer rule.
It says that when data moves back and
forth across this channel,
between slow memory and fast memory,
it does so in chunks of size L words.
That is,
consider the following scenario.
Suppose you want to load a word
at address x from main memory.
The block transfer rule says you
actually have to pay to move
an additional L minus 1 near bywords.
Now which words come with the word
at x depend on how your data is
aligned in slow memory.
In other words, when you design
an algorithm in this model,
data alignment might be another
issue you have to consider.
Still, most real-life memory
systems do block transfers.
So you need to think about
multi-level memories and
block transfers when designing high
performance algorithms, like it or not.
As I've stated it, this model implies
two major costs you need to think about
when designing algorithms.
First, how many operations
does the algorithm require?
In other words, what's the computational
work that the processor needs to do?
Just like the concept of work
in the work span model for
a parallel machine, the concept of work
in this I/O model will generally depend
on the input size n.
Then there's the second cost.
How many block transfers does
the algorithm need to do?
As you might expect, the number of
transfers might depend on both the size
of the fast memory as well
as the block transfer size.
Let's denote the number
of transfers by Q, and
refer to it as the algorithms
I/O complexity.
To make this more concrete, let me walk
you through a very simple example.
Suppose you want to sum
the elements of an array of size n.
You know the processor needs
to do at least n-1 additions.
Or asymptotically,
that's big omega of n operations.
What about memory transfers?
Intuitively, you know you need to make
at least one pass through the data.
That suggests a natural
lower bound on transfers.
That's the ceiling of n divided by L.
The ceiling accounts for the fact
that if n is not a multiple of L,
then you need to pay for
a partial transfer somewhere.
Now, there's another thing to
notice about this expression.
It does not depend on capital Z,
the size of the fast memory.
That makes sense, right?
You only need to touch
each element once.
So whether the fast memory is very large
or very small, it really doesn't matter.
Reduction does not reuse data.
And not reusing data is bad.